the opening scene features an atlas
centur a four-stage rocket that is being
launched into deep space the rocket is
designed in such a way that it uses
energy from the Sun and gravitational
pole of neighboring planets to cross the
solar system this space probe consists
of information about the human race
along with the map of the Earth its
Prime mission is to find intelligent
life forms like that on our planet wao
let's not give us too much credit the
scene then cuts to a school teacher Neil
Clark who is being introduced as one of
Britain's greatest writers of all time
he is interviewed by a beautiful woman
Catherine regarding his best-selling
novel however Neil's speech is
interrupted by his dog Dennis barking
from the crowd suddenly more dogs enter
the venue causing absolute chaos Neil
then abruptly wakes up in his apartment
revealing the entire scenario to be a
dream meanwhile his dog keeps on barking
until his neighbor Fiona comes to his
door to complain as usual this time she
tells him to control his dog or else she
will have to contact the authorities
afterwards Neil takes his dog out for a
walk when he comes across another
neighbor Catherine West he tells her
that he just dreamt of her giving him an
award for his new novel maybe don't tell
her that stupid she asks him if he has
finished the book in real life yet to
which he replies that he's almost done
it turns out Neil has a crush on her and
has for a long time but he is too
embarrassed to tell her in person in the
meantime in outer space the atlas
Centaur probe is sucked into a tube
connected to a gigantic jellyfish shaped
alien ship inside the Extraterrestrial
Galactic Council inspects the probe and
finds the illustrations along with a
peaceful message following this they
assess the Earth and debate whether to
destroy it or consider Humanity for
Council membership one of them thinks
earthlings are barbaric and that they
should destroy Earth for the moral
well-being of The Intergalactic
Community however another Kinder council
member suggests that humans should be
given a chance to prove them themselves
if they succeed they can join the
Society of superior species back on
Earth Catherine is at her office but
she's been arguing on the phone with
Grant a man who's obsessed with her just
then her boss shows up and asks her to
rewrite the questions for her next TV
interview which happens to be with the
best-selling author she tells her to
focus more on the author's past scandals
with the intention of tarnishing his
reputation Catherine protests asserting
the author's widespread popularity but
her objections are disregarded shortly
after after she is approached by the
show's producer James who tells her that
the audience prefers gossip and
character assassination over General
interviews in Space the galactic Council
makes a decision to conduct a test
they'll select a random human and give
them Limitless power to do absolutely
anything if this chosen individual
utilizes these powers for good Humanity
will be embraced into the council
otherwise the entire planet will be
destroyed we're doomed the council then
randomly selects Neil as Earth's
representative granting him 10 10 days
to demonstrate that the planet is worth
saving after this they transfer the
extraordinary powers to Neil who just
fell off his bike due to a van unaware
of his new power he curses the van
driver causing the vehicle to go out of
control on the other hand Katherine
meets with her best friend Rosie at a
cafe and confides in her about Grant in
response her friend suggests considering
Neil whom she also thinks is likable
meanwhile Neil arrives at school late
due to his accident he tries to slip
past the principal's office unnoticed
but is caught the prin principal
frustrated by his habitual tardiness
reprimands him and wishes to replace him
if he could Neil then proceeds to his
classroom but he hesitates to enter when
he sees his Rowdy students later on he
has his lunch with his colleague Rey who
seems to be upset because he's unable to
impress his Crush Dorothy he then asks
Neil about one thing he would do if he
had unlimited power our hero humorously
mentions make his Gog regurgitate his
notes that he swallowed unbeknownst to
him Dennis actually throws up the notes
that magically become intact he adds
that if he really wanted to improve his
life he'd have alien spaceships destroy
the classroom of students that he hates
all of a sudden they hear a loud
explosion upon rushing to check they see
that the classroom is indeed destroyed
in the aftermath Neil returns home and
starts talking to Dennis he says that
the incident was just a coincidence
because he wouldn't harm anyone if given
the power to prove that he's powerless
he casually orders his dog's mess to
clean itself much to his surprise
Dennis's poop walks towards the bathroom
and dives into the toilet I want a mo
thinking that he's hallucinating he
rushes to the kitchen and grabs a drink
during this he accidentally spills The
Whiskey Bottle to test his abilities
again he wishes for the whiskey to get
back into the bottle at first nothing
happens but when he tries a second time
while waving his hand the liquid
surprisingly snakes back into its bottle
leaving him in utter shock now that Neil
realizes he can do anything by simply
waving his hand he wishes his old
whiskey to be replaced with a new one
unex expectedly the bottle hops out and
breaks into a nearby liquor store
triggering the alarm he then runs away
but the police start chasing him just
when he is about to be caught Neil
wishes to be at home eating with his dog
lo and behold his wish comes true and he
vanishes from the scene so far Neil has
killed a bunch of kids thrown out a
bunch of poop and robbed a liquor store
I wonder what the aliens think once home
Neil realizes that the earlier explosion
was actually caused by him in an attempt
to make things right he makes a wish for
everyone who is ever passed to be alive
again as a result all the dead people
Rise Up from the cemetery and approach
his house seeing this Neil hurriedly
clarifies that only those who died in
the prior explosion should be returned
to life he soon comes up with a better
idea and wishes for the explosion to
have never happened this reverses
everything and he finds himself in the
school cafeteria again after this he
goes to his class and sees the students
are back in their irritating State he
then wishes that all of his students
become kind and diligent His Wish is
immediately granted Ed and the classroom
becomes quiet unlike before Neil just
restructured the brain chemistry of a
bunch of children way to go Neil
afterwards Neil notices the principal
from a distance and waves his hand to
make him be nice to him he then walks
past him and receives praise later in
the staff room Neil observes Ray trying
to talk to Dorothy but is consistently
rebuffed feeling bad he wishes for the
woman to warship his friend and seconds
later it happens that's definitely a
criminal offense on his way home Neil
playfully wishes to become the president
president of the US which results in
numbers of armed guards arriving at the
scene and escorting him to the car soon
after they are ambushed by some asants
prompting Neil to wish himself back home
later he stands in front of the bathroom
and makes weird wishes such as having
the body of Albert Einstein weird choice
that dude was shaped like an egg then he
chooses the body of a great athlete and
so on before retiring to bed he also
wishes to see Catherine's room
downstairs upon doing so he notices her
in undergarments ironing her clothes he
accidentally makes a noise which catches
her attention thus he hastily reverses
the process and also makes her forget
what just happened how have the aliens
not blown up the planet yet the
following day Neil confides his
exceptional power in Rey who initially
refuses to believe it to prove it he
makes a skeleton talk and jump outside
he also performs some magic such as
covering the entire room with flowers
all of these demonstrations ultimately
convince Rey leaving him in shock I'll
swear Grant approaches Catherine in the
street and tries to to convince her to
go on a date with him however she
declines and firmly asks him to leave
before departing he hands her the keys
to his apartment in case she changes her
mind later that night Catherine is in
her apartment talking to her best friend
about the guys in her life during this
she expresses her liking towards Neil So
Rosie suggests that she approach him
meanwhile in space a scientist alien
reports that the galactic power has some
glitches in it in order to fix it they
have to take back the power that has
been given to Neil for a while at the
same time Neil aware that he has lost
his power makes a wish for Catherine to
be in love with him coincidentally he
hears a knock on the door and it's
Catherine she unexpectedly kisses him
and the two end up spending a night
together unbeknownst to them they're
being watched by the stalker Grant the
next morning the alien scientist fixes
the power glitch and returns it to Neil
upon waking up Neil Alters the rainy
weather to Sunny and has his clothes
dress him while having breakfast he uses
his power to give his dog the ability to
speak Dennis then starts talking about
his favorite biscuit and also expresses
how much he loves Neil R hump you if
you'd let me Neil not long after
Catherine shows up and apologizes to him
for her unexpected Behavior last night
just then she hears Dennis's voice from
the toilet and Neil pretends that he is
a plumber however when the dog screams I
love you Catherine believes that Neil is
gay prompting her to storm off in anger
in an attempt to explain himself he
follows her and wishes to be on the same
bus that she's on however he ends up on
the bus roof and quickly revises his
wish in the meantime Ray sees Dorothy
worshipping him in her lab along with
some other disciples realizing that it's
all done by Neil he rushes in search of
him shortly after he catches him exiting
the bus he tells him to make things
right but because Neil is in a hurry he
turns Ry into a sausage and continues to
follow Catherine he tries to explain
everything to her but the latter doesn't
listen and leaves Neil then finally
reverts his friend back to his original
form later in the evening Catherine
returns to her apartment where Grant is
waiting for her shocked she lets out a
scream and immediately locks the door
from the outside hearing this Neil
rushes to her and invites her to hide at
his place the two then have dinner
together and Neil finally decides to
reveal his superpowers this is why you
love me isn't that great but before he
can prove it to her Grant breaks into
the apartment and starts quarreling with
Neil Catherine tries to stop them but
when they persist she leaves the place
in Anger following this Neil uses his
powers to stick him in the walls and
place him in a flower pot he then tells
Grand gr that he can easily provide him
with millions of dollars if he's nice
but can also make him disappear with a
mere wave of his hand this Revelation
leaves Grant in a State of Shock just
then Neil gets distracted by his dog and
Grant takes the opportunity to knock him
down from behind a while later he
regains his Consciousness and finds
himself restrained in Grant's apartment
the latter has taken Dennis hostage and
threatens him to start fulfilling a list
of wishes in front of him these wishes
include providing big ears and webbed
feet to all the English man and changing
the color of British police's uniform to
Pink Grant is a fraking idiot on the
other hand Catherine suddenly realizes
that Neil might be in danger and returns
back to his apartment there she finds Ry
hiding in a closet from Dorothy's
Pursuit the two then head to Grant's
house in search of Neil in the meantime
Grant is now seen dressed up as a
high-ranking officer covered with medals
a short while after Catherine and Ray
arrive to rescue Neil who then reverses
all of Grant's wishes before turning him
into a dog he also stops Dorothy from
warshipping Ry ultimately bringing
everything back to normal but now
everyone's disappointed in him because
of problems he's put them through later
Neil awaits Katherine's return home and
apologizes for everything however she
asserts that she cannot be with someone
who might make her do things against her
will this leaves the man devastated
prompting him to return to his place
sadly realizing that he was being
selfish the entire time he now decides
to use his powers to solve The World's
problems finally he then grants everyone
as much food as they want and says that
the wars shouldn't happen for any reason
he also grants every person their own
dream house and wishes for the reversion
of global warming however this all
backfires when worldwide obesity flares
all land including the desert gets taken
over for houses and the planet falls
into a global Ice Age faced with the
unintended consequences Neil decides to
reverse all of his wishes disheartened
by his personal life and unsuccessful
attempts to improve the World Neil
contemplates committing the unthinkable
he jumps off the bridge but Dennis also
leaps off after him as a result Neil is
forced to rescue his pet and
consequently himself afterward Dennis
tells his master to give the power to
him emphasizing his unwavering obedience
and lack of selfish intentions Neil
thinks for a while and obliges man A lot
of people are about to get humped
meanwhile the aliens decide that Earth
is not worthy it turns out that the
galactic Council has an inverted
understanding of morality it sees
dominance as good and weakness as Evil
And the fact of Neil trying to end Wars
and make the lives of others better is
considered to be a sign of weakness
believing that the earthlings are weak
the aliens finally decide to destroy
Earth but in an unexpected turn of
events Dennis who now possesses all the
power wishes that the source of power be
destroyed this results in the
destruction of the alien spaceship as
well as the associated planets reverting
Neil back to his apartment the next day
Neil now without the powers musters the
courage to ask Catherine out for dinner
much to his Elation she accepts his
proposal on the other hand it's revealed
that Dennis still retains the powers
since he only wished for the source of
the power to be destroyed not the powers
themselves is the genocide of the alien
species really a happy ending I don't
know subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching